In today's video we are taking a look at a popular and easy to do illusion and seeing just how far we can push it
Guys a few years ago action lab did an amazing video where he showed you how to draw on water now
That's a pretty cool experiment now
I have seen a lot of different youtubers who have done this
But I've never seen anybody try and stack their art together to form sort of an illusion
I want to try that
I want to try different types of dry erase markers to see if they have any sort of difference and see if we can actually
Get a barrier to for them with a pane of glass and just some hot glue sticks. Here's the basic idea
We have several different types of dry erase markers and several panes of glass now
We should be able to get our drawings to float on the surface of water
so by adding a waterproof barrier to our piece of glass we should be able to stack them up and see if we can get
An illusion to form. This should be pretty simple
We've got just a few panes of glass here and we're gonna try and form a waterproofing barrier
Just using some hot glue sticks. It should be pretty simple. The reason I'm not using any sort of just
Pre-made dish like Pyrex is when you have a cooking pyrex dish if you've ever seen these other videos before
They tend to have a sort of a warped bottom now
My goal here is to try and get lots of overlay pieces of art the way to do that is have a perfectly smooth surface
So I'm gonna have to build these myself
This is not the most conventional method of using hot glue sticks
But you guys have seen me do weird stuff with them before so why not?
The reason these are gonna be so nice is they're kind of rubbery
So when we stack the panes of glass they shouldn't split. We'll see
Now the reason that using glass is so important when you're trying to draw on water is
It's a non-porous surface and you need something. That is very very smooth anything. That's
Textured means that the dry erase marker is going to sort of sink into it and it's not going to release as you'd be even
With the release agent that's in these markers. So I want this very very smooth glass
But what that means is the hot glue is less likely to stick
Let's see if it's watertight
So far so good
All right, so we've got our glass panes and they're more or less waterproof so those are pretty much good to go
But before we start drawing on those, I wouldn't do a few tests
Now action lab said that he had the best results with glass bowls or anything that has a very smooth non-porous surface
But also with using hot water so we're gonna try a few different types. I've got a few different types of markers
I've got Expo markers, which is what most everyone seems to use
But we've also got a few off-brand markers and I want to see if there's a difference
We've also got three different temperatures of water
I've just got cold tap water just sort of a lukewarm and then one that we actually microwave to get really really hot
So I want to see what that's gonna do first test. Just our black Expo marker
we're gonna try it with cold water lukewarm and then hot
Keep this very simple what we just do some tests or some cold water. And so I'm gonna go ahead and say that did
Nothing, the ink is still very much a dear to the bottom of the glass. It's not even wanting to pull up
All right. Let's try the lukewarm water
All right, same thing not much happening there
I'll also be curious to see if the off-brand markers or if a different color works any better
Well, that was different
So with the hot water immediately you're starting to see it crack
Again, not floating to the surface
Alright action lab used blue Expo in his first video. He's done a few of these there's one
He actually does a magnetic animation with them with a magnetic putty
When I could forget in that crazy today, but he did manage to make a blue Expo marker work fast. Let's try it
We were seeming to have the most success with the hottest water. So we'll go ahead and do that
But definitely parts of it came to the surface
That's definitely thinking about it it's not keeping the shape we wanted. All right, so a little float to the surface
Not keep me in shape. Let's try that one one more time. Whew is definitely working better?
Alright so this bottom might just be too hot
I'm not pouring it gently enough because it's just falling to pieces, but it is floating to the surface
Let's go ahead and try one of our off-brand see if that works any better and be shocked if it does
But it's got a try
It actually released much better. However, it did fall apart. Now. It's almost looking like this is dissolving in the really really hot water
So I do think we need that mix between hot and lukewarm. So I'm gonna mix those. We're gonna try again
There's definitely a temperature factor here and that's pretty cool. So we've got off-brand Expo Expo Expo
Off-brand and then three of our tinier Expo markers
Just cooling down the hot water just a little so it's warm to the touch it's not going to burn me
There we go
All right. Let's see here. What's working best blue green, so that's interesting. The orange pigment was surprising
I didn't think that would work. We've also got our red Expo month of floating to the surface. That's good to know
It is interesting to note though that the green and the blue are just sort of dissolving pink orange is working better than the rest
Well almost all right, let's go ahead and try on one of our flat surfaces see if we can get any better results
He's waving at us and he broke
Well almost
Purple is holding together a little bit better
Also not wanting to rise to the surface
However, the blue even though it is sort of dissolving as it goes
It's forming some really fun patterns. So we might try that instead
Let's just try and see if we get some fun patterns on the surface of the water
All right
so success rate is varying wildly depending on the marker that we're using the heat of the water and
Smaller drawings or drawings with more ink tend to be working a little bit better
So I'm going to attempt that and then we're gonna attempt to stack this
All right, see if this works guys
Some of it is definitely lifting off better than others
Well, that's interesting just because you can see that some of the colors lifted off and some did not
You've got one mobile design here
Which is at this point just a very large stringing mist
That's cool so you can layer and switch it up see then get these two back together ha ha ha
That's fun. You can kind of manipulate it to go back to where it's supposed to be
We go the other one underneath it. You could do some fun optical illusions with this. Can you draw on water?
And can you layer it for optical illusions? Yeah, you can is it practical?
Probably not but it's a lot of fun
We go
Guys some of our favorite projects are now available as a subscription
Click the link below to see if you can guess what the first one might be guys
That's not all you know
we've always got more for you to see that box up at the top will take you to our latest video and that box the
Bottom is what YouTube thinks you could be watching next hit this bomb in the middle to subscribe to the club
So you never miss out on the fun. Don't forget to ring that Bell and we'll see in the next one. Talk to you then.thx bye topi